this video is sponsored by better help
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people citizens of the reject Nation
it's me Tera ericon alongside
Andrew Flash Gordon what is going on I
love how you said that look look at my
t-shirt guys dead inside but Jolly AF I
like it yeah we're going to watch I
almost said 22 Jump Street but that is
the name you were on you were on track I
think I was maybe going to say Jump
Street 22 22 Jump straight we're
watching it you guys so listen we're
stoked I mean I actually am excited cuz
I really love the first one so leave a
like type a comment say how cool we are
and also don't forget ring the
bell ring the bell also thanks to
prepper for helping us edit down these
videos also if you want to be super sexy
you need to get on the patreon because
you could syn up with your own copy
watch the whole thing with me and Andrew
what that's insane Greg and John offer
exclusive highlights and watch alongs
over there on patre so get sexy that's
what we call you super sexy over there
get with it are you excited are you
stoked what do you got to tell the
people Andrew how are you so excited I
love the first movie and uh that line at
the end of the first one y'all going to
college so I'm stoked to go to college
with Channing Tatum and Jonah Hill let's
do it let's do
it getting hyped just from the music
yeah right and those logos oh my God
there's a
previous I love it oh you lucky you even
graduated this huh you want to be
friends that was my favorite part of the
first one those two yeah the
chemistry all right all right right do
you remember the lobster I don't
remember that you two sons of [__]
are going to college
woo College here we go watch that whole
movie we just needed the recap and is
associated with water and femininity
While y by
contract zoom out man this is BS I
thought we're going to actual College
not online
college dope car think of this one from
the first one they got in the impound
tide comes in at 10:30 a.m. then it will
return to the
Sea
there's nobody in the car I love it I
wonder how many times they improved that
scene that's the ghost Yost neelon
biggest Traer of illegal Goods in Metro
City good actor I teamed up with the
Mexican cartel and they're running all
this [__] through the port what the hell
are we supposed to be buying I don't
know what are you doing I got a new
identity it's going to be killer I'm
going need you to improvise okay okay I
don't want to improvise I'm going to
need you to improvise [__] improvise
I don't want to do
it I need absolute silence on the
character dude you're in a movie of
improvising can you give me like a head
start on I need AB I need absolute
Sil do a little Zip Zap
[Music]
zop oh my goodness you had time to do
makeup that's great and I love the
western music too yeah this
walk serious right now oh I'm
sold [__] still sleepy what's up homie
Wolverine looks like Wolverine yeah
that's [__] man you're sleepy
everyone saying the body sleepy he like
the Mexican Wolverine and when he
talking my name is Jeff
what tell about man tell that crazy
adventure you guys had I don't know what
you're talking about a man who you
telling the story last night that's me
every time I try to do an accent it was
D and
Diego and
Swiper who was that you choked out man B
no
man can't believe the TKS I have to deal
with these
days makes me miss the '90s good
decade you want check out the
goods and shut up right where' you find
his Gringo man mfor his son's concert
and
[Music]
[__] and they're both so
white what is it guns drugs oh oh my God
that legitimately scared me ah it's my
back oh almost gave me like it felt like
alien oh my
[Applause]
God whoa take him off guys they're
cops
oh
oh in here oh my
God no not the
damn byebye pretty girl I'm going to
shoot you in the
face what are you doing oh Dam oh all
right man get up here I can't do that
climb around come on climb around yeah
it's really
easy come all right you good yeah all
you got to do is walk now okay
okay
get up
here oh my God I have a panic attack oh
my gosh guys just get
here oh my
goodness
Terminator you under I said pull truck
over whoa you owe me a card better be a
oh now I understand that Terminator
reference oh [__]
oh my goodness they both
holy
ow that was a cool
shot is that a hickey this uh this was
actually uh an octopus related
incident nobody gave a [__] about the
Jump Street reboot when you first came
on this is meta I like it so now this
department has invested a lot of money
to make sure Jump Street keeps
going well the commissioner convinced
this debacle happened because you
weren't doing the same undercover
student thing you did the first time
always worse the second time around one
gets possessive the other runs away you
begin a slow painful unraveling is this
foreshadowing yeah what if we actually
went into the Secret Service and like
tried to protect the White House I think
I'm saying we I'm going to ask you to
stop talking do the same thing as last
time okay keep it simple I can't believe
the Koreans bought their church back I
mean good thing there was an even bigger
abandoned church directly across the
street yeah that's convenient 22 Cher be
right back across the street just next
door 23 ourselves
not very meta as you called it yeah way
more expensive for no reason look at
Dixon's office oh you guys did really
well last time you earned it yeah you
[__] like Jump Street now hey girl
hey 22 Jump Street is the lick and I got
a big ass raise to babysit you two
again I love how met this is this is
great 21 Jump Street and Korean Jesus
come on Korean Jesus is right there
that's Vietnamese Jesus you racist
sacriligious sack of [__]
look at that Vietnamese Jesus just
dripping swag good hey hey look alive
boys yo
jenko same assignment we're going back
to high school your ass look like you're
about 50 you going to MC State they look
50 somebody's out there they cooking up
a new drug it's Aderall mixed with
ecstasy mixed with God knows whatever
sounds great I want to try that wi wi no
you dumb mother WiFi stands for work
hard yes play hard yes they get laser
focus for about 4 hours of studying and
then they party like it's goddamn
1999 who's this that's Cynthia Watts he
was a student at MC State took some
Wi-Fi got locked out of her dorm ended
up falling off the wo o yikes that's her
buying drugs on campus and that's the
dealer find him and we find a supplier
it is so refreshing to have a case with
a black victim we care so much more
because she's black H We Care equally
it's a tie really oh my God no we're not
if it was a white person I wouldn't even
care one less cracker ass cracker to
worry about oh my God why every time you
speak I want to throw the
up my goodness I love every time ice
cube disses him it never gets old yeah
yeah cuz most of the time it's warranted
anyways what's up bro High School right
school oh so tight oh this is never seen
someone so excited to live in the dorm
yeah right oh dooke that's a that looks
like okay oh yeah gross it's really
incredible how many so dorm rooms look
so alike yeah just in all different
schools I mean Bean back chair hilarious
shirt that signals we drink alcohol M I
love bear pong some bakon machine that
my mom got me you don't understand how
it works I love the titling in this
Q-tips be back chair a comfort that I
will not wash for the next 6 months they
are clearly ready for college what up
fellas we across the whole neighbors oh
twins's up man yangs man what going on
man Yang what's up did you say the yangs
yeah Dad Chinese man my mom's not
Chinese she's
black we're brothers too you like one of
yall older you got crows feet into your
eyes man I mean well even if you're a
little older that's cool girls here love
old the D especially doing spring
break oh my gosh I love that kind of
want something that's a little deeper
reallys
[Music]
deep the same this is
amazing that's crazy we have that
brother connection too I wonder if they
do that in real life on accident
[Music]
that's complete improv yep you took a
bullet from me all right I didn't it
sucked I do it again no way it's my turn
I owe you life dead goe bathroom oh wow
oh hello I'm not going to take a [__]
the entire time I'm here
I stop just exhausted from inventing
Facebook or whatever website people
already
use so go to all Cynthia's classes and
activities ask around about the drug and
find out who the dealer is dude in human
sexuality do you get to or do you just
get to watch people neither probably
just watch adult
films I've got a first impression for
you oh y'all like psychology Tracy Mor
my
God nobody wow you looking for some
Wi-Fi yeah man be sick go to the police
station walk in and ask your captain to
see the evidence from cuz you're a AR I
think you're mistaken you're literally
wearing your badge I didn't look
down you guys play football no this is
actually my laptop yeah I'm taking notes
right now I'm kidding it's a
football what has been the result of the
War on Drugs well it's definitely harder
to get drugs the average price of
cocaine has dropped 70% in the last 30
years then your dealer is probably
selling you some pretty steep on [__]
cheap okay college is a wonderful place
this is where you get to decide who you
actually are instead of the person that
you're clearly pretending to be right
now why are you saying this stuff that's
exactly the answer I wanted Mr McQuade I
want you to question what I'm saying
this is the basis of this whole course
he did it even though he didn't
understand I can really say whatever I
want George Washington was a black
lesbian the Eiffel tow made a they can't
fire me I'm
indestructible I'm sleeping with two of
my students her and her actually am this
is an awesome
class sign me up the only way you can
fail this class is by not becoming who
you truly are please respond to my
text oh god oh man uh we just need you
guys to fill in the blank in a sentence
that we're going to set up so it'll go
like this oh I'm so hungry I wish I had
a tampon
[Music]
okay let's try it one more time oh I've
got to get home so I can feed my
[Laughter]
boner what would that girl's in my side
class go talk to her you come talk to
her with me stop being go talk to her go
like dude you scored with Brie Larson
last film you know how to talk to you
know what's up was a high school but you
still I talked to we're in the the same
site class oh yeah pills pills pills a
sign of the times that rhymes Amanda
binds Cynthia that girl who died did you
know her she lived across the hall from
me so what why do you care so much I'm
writing a um slam poem wouldn't it be
better to just to like plan the stuff
out ahead of time and make sure it's
funny and then not say it in front
of that's not the point of impr stand up
comedy that's probably what you should
do cuz that stuff's
funny anybody have anything they want to
share let's see what you get do you
really do poetry improvisor I do and I
will you got somebody what oh No uhoh
Slam
poetry
yelling
[Laughter]
angry waving my hands a lot
specific point of view on things
Cynthia
Cy Julia
Roberts Julia
[Music]
robs Rich herd
gear
Cynthia you're dead you are dead oh my
God that's for Cynthia he's
dead Standing
Ovation I don't have a single lead I do
I hear you can get Wi-Fi on campus
anywhere 24/7 product placement
Doritos baby best flavor well we need
help we need to consult an expert yo dud
you got a minute
got oh that was funny that makes sense
cuz that's that's what they did to him
in the first movie [__] you are looking
fit a you should get some tips from this
guy he's looking good oh Dave Franco I'm
liberated totally you know they gave me
a it's awesome you guys want to see
it take your word for it Eric's seen it
Eric's been all up in that [__] A that
right Eric you guys got to get me the
out of here I'm Eric's [__] no you're
not yes I am I'm your [__] it's a
lesson to y'all don't get in trouble and
go to jail I am such a [__] when Aunt
Flo shows up it bleeds so much it's
crazy oh my it's like the elevator door
is opening in The
Shining I've never seen that movie but I
understood that reference yes I know but
we can't see his face we don't know who
it is we don't know who it is I'm Smith
my parants are full of Duty yeah that's
you you sort of sound like that that
doesn't sound anything it doesn't sound
anything like me did you even bother to
look at the picture yeah huh there's a
reflection right here oh find the tattoo
find the dealer good eye I don't know I
do a lot of stupid tattoos to drunk kids
you remember that stupid tattoo I've
never gotten a tattoo you guys wait did
those twins did they say boom did they
say that I can't remember did they or I
don't know maybe they didn't maybe I'm
wrong I don't think they did I might
have did it on a football player I think
I know know exactly who he's talking
about you you little walk on can't like
move around oh it's going to be so funny
watching Jonah Hill to
football [__] dude I'm so sorry it's all
right man don't worry about it man e
ow I got it I got oh my goodness dude
I'm sorry I got my Q-tip in your meat
bro oh man I got my I got my meat in
your Q-tip oh it's w it's Wyatt Russell
Kurt Russell son oh it's like a meat
cute it's like a meat are they in love
right now it seems like it it's a meat
cute sandwich me and this guy are having
a meat
cute he looks he looks a lot like Kurt
Russell too Brad Brad wait uh yeah yeah
Brad I'm zuk Z nice to meet you nice to
meet you too man oh yeah he he so looks
like oh my gosh they're in love yeah he
has his eyes like 100% I did not know
that that was his
son
who love walk on day
now tattoo if you see that safety lineup
That D though hit me quicker oh yeah I
didn't know you had Wheels like that bro
it's funny cuz he's my brother so he's
getting Jelly we have this Rush party I
thought you know you could come by and
meet the guys it'd be really fun you too
you can come to see also I said a bunch
of stuff earlier that you didn't
acknowledge so
great and he didn't even acknowledge he
said that I love it enough to confirm
that rooster has that bazooka tattoo is
he wearing a joker up dude same puka
dude
[__] dude I knew we were going to be
connected just like that guys tired
together and get
married that's the best line right there
nothing's going to top
that I've been to so many parties where
that's been me I'm just like sitting
there awkwardly in the corner awkwardly
in the corner I'm like nobody likes me
so rooster oh yeah no uh we' met before
oh really I don't remember that at all
you must have a really plain face n it
was so nice chatting nice to meet
you what are you doing dude serious
right now you you're being weird you've
been
weird I'm wondering if it's it's
actually meat cute guy that might be
selling the drugs you think it's him you
think it's him with the tattoo yeah that
it might be a little reversal we didn't
see coming yeah probably I mean just cuz
it seems like it's so obvious that it's
the other
one my
gosh I miss so much come on let's go all
right yeah we saw on the truck scene
he's clearly not capable of doing that
yeah there's no way I'm just going to go
home I don't know parkour so yeah this
is me um I'm an art
major okay not a model major yeah I love
to be alone just love when you're
sitting there in a room and you're just
there with your thoughts and you're like
oh my gosh I'm alone anyone ever love me
or whatever and
like he's so good he's so good at improv
if you don't want to be alone tonight we
are going to go hang out at the art
building if you want to
come okay okay that's me when someone's
like want to go see some art okay okay
okay I expect tonight would go in a way
that you wouldn't expect but what I
didn't expect was tonight do I see a two
peeking through on his oh I I didn't so
you guys hang out here a lot I wasn't
being a we'll look again oh my God he's
in this why is that actor remember the
show um love or on Netflix see how he
has a line on his yeah that I did
see whoa
uh get out of
[Applause]
[Music]
town I guess Channing T's making up for
the the fact he didn't go to college so
he's kind of living vicariously through
his undercover job right now totally
feel like they both are oh it's only two
I thought it was late do you want to
come in it's only two I thought it was
late you kidding I mean Tara and I are
old so like yeah so 10:00 is late very
late go post bro you guys might want to
hold on cuz this [__] is coming down oh
oh what is this is that the one what's
that right there oh it's my old high
school it's not a boom okay so it is
it's it's Wyatt Russell he has it you
called that all you got to do is join
the team yeah
yes yeah
dude uhoh uh-oh look that's me is it the
one no that's the one oh it is boom
booms well now you really got to play on
the team so you can get closer to uh oh
you hey good call now he's got to F out
of out of love with his with his bro his
dude bro and now you shall be accused of
seeing the film yeah what's up with
it how you doing hi he got to sleep with
that model and her underwear well it's
still early that was this for you fun
for me it's a good time yeah right I
enjoyed it
yeah this is why I don't drink huh
you're like the loudest climaxer I've
ever
heard look I I just want you to know I'm
not like a hit it and quit it type fella
H is she a hited in I mean you're cool
with just hooking up yeah I mean no I
mean I'm glad you said something cuz I
don't even know if I like you when I'm
sober no I know was great good you're
good at it and I'll text you 3 to 5
minutes or something all right 3 to five
minutes oh boy one of us got laid last
night sh don't wake up my bluing on the
red eye hasn't gotten a wink of
sleep talking missionary we're talking
when I'm on top and she's on her back a
she's smart she's an art major I will
give you some DB SM are you crazy are we
going to talk about how weird you were
today with Dixon look I don't think the
tattoo means what you think it means I I
mean for all we know a lot of people
could have that tattoo this tattoo this
absurdly specific tattoo yeah in that
specific area too zuk has a tattoo we've
been looking for this tattoo for days do
you understand this means zuk is the
dealer I really want you guys to hang
out he's in denial Tera yeah cuz he
loves him guys Ken you just give us some
space we're really trying to figure
something out we need to focus okay not
going to have a trouble focusing man
yeah man those crispy trees got mad wifi
in them oh no I've eaten six of these oh
God who showed you Wi-Fi yeah man
Cynthia gave us a buttload and in the
exchange we wrote hologic paper for oh
damn you feel anything no do you feel
anything no but I have a super high
tolerance
oh I'm so focused I so Focus
to I love that they're on this Mission
like this it's
great this is awesome like performing
The Sober got to be so difficult too
yeah maybe they just slam like seven Red
Bulls Maybe yeah not
B going Mission Impossible you know it's
not
Lan
[Music]
safety
awesome I like that epic music to slow
down going
up nothing's happening is making the
glass cutting
sound
that's no fun at all it's okay you're on
drugs we'll forgive you let's do
this should have done the laser cutter
[Music]
yeah don't to Dr some I
don't time to prove zuk's a dealer qu
obviously right I mean the guy is the
guy is all time the guy let's be honest
I mean like he was open up beer cans
with his eyeballs you got he's got to
make it for that he's got to
[Music]
m r poor Doug I got a bad feeling about
this guy dude I was talking to him for a
second he's got a big mouth I feel like
whole
thing you know it's interesting in that
class where the teacher said you can be
anything you want there it said Star
Wars in the back and then he just said I
have a bad feeling about this which is a
line in all the Star Wars so little had
a Trope there love that sh I'm trying to
hear them be nice about
me I think somebody up
there above the Star Wars it said
Coca-Cola and at the party they were all
drinking Coca-Cola
sponsors oh no that last one was not
really covered very well the other ones
were but that last one was
[Music]
not he just throws his backpack into a
tree why do you think he saw us no
you're just paranoid because we're about
to trip balls no I'm paranoid because he
could be dangerous we're fine look we
made
here oh oh waa dud that scared the crap
out of me that
me whoa oh this must be them getting
hazed because they decided to accept
them yeah exact exactly yeah for sure
they're going to kill us
J where you
going oh they are tripping such balls
that would be terrible having a back
trip I think we are
tripping my side's so much scarier than
yours and they really did up the budget
in this film
yeah I finally got my
[Laughter]
[Music]
Lambo
I love that song don't go oh my God no
stay here stop it you're dragging me
down why would you drag me down it's
okay just stay in the buddy system get
out of the car get out of the
car under knes you already know don't
you what oh it's definitely hazing yeah
open your mouth it's going to be like
tequila yeah yeah exactly a vodka
to
vodka welcome to the Frat Boys if you
don't make it through tonight you're
dead to all of us rooster light the
torch I want to know how anyone's liver
is still intact if you were in a frat or
a sority
yeah oh God I I would literally just be
puking I'd be puking vomit I wouldn't be
P I would be projectile vomiting you'd
be it'd be like the Exorcist yes exactly
like it we watched that together right
sure did
[Music]
yeah and they're doing this while
drugged up
yeah I'm I'm happy for Chaine Tatum he's
living out his dream right now he
finally got to go to
college well if you think about it the
first movie like Jonah Hill got to go to
the prom and be popular and now this
movie it's for him but I mean I guess
for Jonah Hill he got to sleep with the
really hot walk
[Laughter]
yeah
nice I can't this is disgusting I can't
do this anymore and now for my favorite
event I'm not doing I'm not doing this
is what we have to do to win their trust
is supposed to be fun it's fun for you
it's not fun for me I don't know maybe
we should just go our separate ways
maybe we should just just investigate
different people split up did you really
just say that yeah remember the
foreshadowing in the beginning of the
movie they called it Nick Offerman
called it don't like the idea of doing
stuff separately we can still
investigate together now it'll be an
open thing you want an open
investigation this is great this is
great the subtext yep you want an open
investigation okay so I guess I'll catch
you later then you okay let's hug it out
you can't hug me right now money for cab
no I don't need money for a cab this is
really emotional right now yeah I I
really like this scene a lot
City well I guess he rejected it right
yeah I guess you're
right drops
back nice we've got time for one last
place
damn solid looks like MC st's got a new
power couple Z and
McQuay
what get around you man I can't jump got
broken oh my
goodness bro time
[__] he's just sitting around watching
them oh is that is that the girl he
hooked up with I think so or oh no he's
testing
the music CU well they said one of you
is going to get him don't come in I'm
having with a human woman human
woman hey oh his parents I love them
it's parents
weekend wonderful you're dating someone
yeah they're definitely dating Doug Maya
these are my parents so this is the girl
hi I'm Annie I'm your new mother-in-law
my goodness well my parents are here too
mine H Ice Cube
oh no yikes Dad this is Doug a guy that
I'm
dating how's your classes going
Doug you're in the neighborhood and to
be fair he did not know he didn't know
nor did Ice Cube say to him hey my
daughter goes here do not sleep yeah he
did not specify that yeah he should have
to be
fair I'm sorry that's not Jonah Hill's
but que laa is in this oh was that I
didn't even I was just looking at Ice
Cube's reaction how did you two meet we
met at a poetry slam and then he sted me
back to my dorm room stalked her uh oh
and then we hung out and we watched a
movie actually we watched it a couple
times
yeah kind of black man do to get us some
water around here give the give the guy
some water he's black he's been through
a
lot where are you from originally I'm
straight out of compon but my husband's
from Northridge
oh we're not too far from either those
three give godamn string
beans I like fruit but this pork
[__] he's under a lot of press at work
what's up play want go to the movies
break your M bre your
oh my God I wonder if he had to nail
this the first time yeah I had to cuz
they're like we can't how many turkeys
or chicken can they go
through
uhoh sorry dude is that it he sells
drugs WiFi you know you can always tell
me something if you want to get it off
your chest you know I'm always here for
you right what are you trying to say no
nothing everything that happened with
Cynthia and Wi-Fi this is not the time
to do when he's spotting you but it's
good for the movie I have a friend who
knows a guy ATC and they want me to make
a tape and I want you to be on it with
me that was quite a reveal it's going to
be our shot we're like the dynamic duo
bro we're like Batman and Robin not
Captain America and the Winter Soldier
do you understand that reference I do
cuz I watched that show and he was on
that show yeah the whole time I didn't
know he's Kurt Russell's son yeah you
really think I can make it at UMC you
could make it into the Hall of Fame oh
well that's you you're going to be in
like the anals of football history dude
you could make it into the anals of
football history
too I just don't understand what his
problem is with you specifically I don't
Jesus that makes
no Doug why does my dad have your phone
number I don't I don't know maybe the
school directory or something let's do
something that would distract us so we
don't have to think about him oh my God
his is it okay if we just talk
okay you're a genius dude are you sure
it's not too much though no
Sho best video ever they should post
that on YouTube get a lot of hits yeah
another star wi Jin buy me a beer oh my
God they're like brothers I can't
believe we've been talking all night oh
my God it's 8:00 got class you can help
yourself to whatever you need and um
yeah I'm so sorry I don't know how
people go to class at 8:00 p.m. at night
ridiculous you guys High School I
started class at 7:40 p.m oh a am I
thought she said am oh she did say am
okay I thought oh it's the morning now
stuff wasn't meant for you was meant to
be private so am I supposed to just sit
here and act like I hear every one of
your
problems you're more messed up than
Cynthia was and she went to the school
shrink three times a week why but he
gave her a ton of pills and [__] maybe
he could give you something
oh she would be a good psychiatrist or
therapist this that
character is it going to be a character
we've already seen what do you think
you've been predicting correctly I'm
like the psychiatrist is it is it pat oh
is it that Psych is it that psychologist
class remember the psych psychiatric
teacher that they the one who was
talking like Tracy Pat yeah the one
who's talking like Tracy Murphy oh yep
you're right totally called it now now I
shall be accused of seeing the movie you
think you're the first Partners to come
in here looking for help only to try to
run when you're first faced with talking
with me you know we were Partners a
relationship is something that requires
constant work which is what I thought we
learned in high school so you are high
school sweethearts I mean they
technically are yeah I just feel like
sometimes he's not even trying
anymore sometimes I like to have the
participants make physical contact why
don't you hold hands okay I'm not doing
that okay reach out your hand he's
literally reach ing out for you you
won't hold my hand I'm not doing that I
kind of needed to do it you got to
interlock it though if you don't
interlock
it this is like the [__] hand move
you got to what I want to be able to
have is this is is this I want to be
able to have that that same thing in
a are you embarrassed of your partner no
not at all okay and why the are you guys
ganging up on me gang up on him that's
such a thing that happens in therapy
with with relationships I teach you
about a principal called embedding look
at the facts matter fact zuk has the
tattoo he knew Cynthia he's still
talking with yeah what did you say
embedding was embedding is our tendency
to latch onto the first bit of
information that we're offered and over
looking or even ignoring contradictory
information recomend you can leave the
room just get the out the first time we
saw the photo of Cynthia buying Wi-Fi
Dixon said this guy's the dealer
everything we've done in thought has
been based on that fact oh oh and we've
ignored all the other Clues oh and it's
what if Cynthia was the dealer
wa wow we have something really really
to tell you
about oh god oh he's ready to shoot
him what the is going on this is what
the is going
on the plot
thickens oh [__] oh [__]
oh my God that delayed the response is
so great Channing Tatum has the best
reactions ever I'm sorry so
good literally yo this is the best thing
ever okay Jonah Hill owns The Improv but
he owns the reactions
[Laughter]
yeah you actually high five sh for your
daughter holy [__] oh my God this
is it's really not that
funny I just want to say that it was
bizarre not to share the fact that your
daughter went to MC State that's what we
said yep what if captain gets to punch
you in the face one time I got something
way better than
that
oh oh man we have to stop treating this
like it's exactly the same as last time
and we got a bigger problem no more
money in the budget what I thought we
had klette
KL you mean car
blanch we did have car blanch not no
more you got that expensive Chase in the
beginning oh my God it's so met up uhhuh
shit's expensive I got them $800 shoes
and you can't even see them up and you
had a couple SE scenes with my daughter
look I apologize about the zuk thing
what if he's like hey got all this wi-fi
let's sell it okay great you apologize
what's that worth man now we have no
lead what are we supposed to do now
police
work yeah kids don't check out books
anymore right I don't think they know
how to
read oh book place library book place a
book I don't think I've ever heard that
a book place you wa up dud hey dude
where are you oh this like reminds me of
when he was late to the Peter Pan thing
like where are you exactly you can do
this alone I'll be back in two hours you
got this just go to the book place I
guess he made it whereas Jonah Hill
didn't make it to the
heang to the in like two minutes well
we'll suspend
disbelief Place think if somebody wants
to show us their operation at least be
on time what do you think the psychology
teacher or oh it's this guy oh I do miss
today what's he doing when people did
normal drugs what is this is he going to
dress up Mexican style again yeah I
wonder well he can't because the guy
would recognize him right away know
right
away
oh now getting it getting it getting it
getting it and he hangs off with a
touchdown these two are and
a he's playing in a game he told you
that can you shut it what's wrong with
those classic drugs from the [__] oh oh
oh oh [__] here you have a sh go right
there okay he's about to meet up with
the supplier hey sh check that out uh oh
God go tackle him you're interrupting a
a really
Stellar what the hell is going on it's
okay it's just a couple of yo what the
did you just say you said you were
sucking his di it's 2014 [__] you
can't use yeah exactly homosexual maybe
and if you know the person you might be
able to call them a queer if they have a
great humor but I don't I'm sorry he
took one human sexuality class he thinks
he's Harvey Milk I understood that
reference Sean Penn why can't you just
use your head for once oh you want me to
use my head fine
oh you [__] are all under
arrest where's your gun what do you have
guns what no I don't we have
guns uh they didn't think that plan
through very
well this way it's FAS oh damn hurry up
okay whoa that was
awesome come I can't jump down I'm not a
Spider-Man yeah buddy do look like
Spider-Man that looks
awesome that's the car back amazing
almost as cool as the Camaro well they
did say the budget is gone so yeah makes
sense please do something about how slow
this thing's
going oh [__] watch out watch
out
oh we can't destroy any more stuff we
can't waste any more of the Department's
money we don't have a
budget
o amazing that's how you get money out
of an ATM you just run it over I'm just
going to run it over next now I'm going
to start doing that dope I got to offer
the scholarship to play football here
next year you can't be a cop and stay
here and play football with Zoo just
when I'm on the football field and I'm
diving for a pass I feel like I can C
when I'm with you it just feels like you
hold me down oh damn dang he's never
going to be able to fly with you on the
football field
sadly dude the brid are out oh cuz he
pull pulled the cord you got to jump you
got to jump jump jump jump oh boy I did
say earlier it's going to go down yeah
woo there it
goes that's a weird thing to celebrate
yeah is that a college thing that I
don't get Maybe
underr hey I'm an officer right just
take me and I'll explain later I don't
know hey who's this doent didn't doing
wait wait wait what are you doing what
are you doing I decided for you stick
with football this is actually sad I
didn't think I was actually going to be
moved like this I was just expecting
comedy yeah they do a good job of
delivering it well and setting it up
really nicely to be like oh that's sad
hey Maya Angelou thanks for lying to
me wait did she find out he's a c uh I
don't know we could we got there
[Applause]
quickly yeah this is going to be great
cuz he's going to realize we're too much
alike and he's going to miss his friend
just wondering we have identified and
arrested one Dr Carl Murphy Oh Wi-Fi
residue throughout his office and had a
close personal relationship with the
deceased feel like it wouldn't be him
that was a setup you're not supposed to
thow rocks what you're not supposed to
throw
rocks he is mad inside the lobster for
one person that that sounds good sounds
delicious love Lobster I would get down
on some lobster right
now hey you want to do anything else
other than about today this is what we
do man dude come on no don't be afraid
why don't I love that I don't remember
the lobster scene from the top but I
love that he's trying to do all the
things that they did yes to try to
recreate the same Bond it's perfect why
don't I remember the lobster was it a
delete uh I don't it might have been I
mean I remember a lot of the first movie
I just don't remember that maybe it was
a deleted scene maybe people let us know
in the comments like you just guys you
just forgot we blanked
it ooh are they going to meet in the
yard right now I believe they are oh
that was cool that's a great turn
transition just came to see how you are
I'm the happiest I've ever been so I'm
just having a great time with myself
glad you're having a good time with
yourself I'm a solo artist now like
Beyonce I used to have the other
Destiny's children but now I'm just a a
lone Superstar like Justin Timberlake no
more in sync no more how are you I'm
pretty great I'm I just chill and you
know how chill zuk zuk's such a chill
guy just say you miss each other and
make out already I just wanted to say
that like I was thinking about the case
I was worried they got the wrong guy for
it that's what we were saying yeah I
looked into the ghost background and I
saw that he pays tuition for a student
at MC State you think the ghost could be
the supplier's dad maybe I think it's
zuk or H I don't know maybe the other
guy the The Jerk guy yeah the other
football player red hair spiky oh yeah I
I don't know who else cuz we haven't
really met any other their characters
maybe the twins I don't know someone's
bringing a [__] ton of that stuff down
to PTO Mexico for spring break we could
go down there what about school and
football and I have time
offerto Mexico nice going to his
homeland from the character at the
beginning that he was yeah one of these
babies a grenade why are you going to
put that is not the place you want to
put
that Mr
spot the music cues in this are so
[Music]
great one finger
H yeah get
it did you not see that I was going
first damn that is awesome
[Music]
wild oh wow mad
WiFi jeez
[Music]
I wish I had that backpack I wish I had
that backpack that backpack full of
money would really help me out oh the
roommate ah that makes that makes
sense ah that makes sense so much sense
I'm sure rewatching it too like looking
at we would have like all these kids
hooked on Wi-Fi then you're going to
bring it back to your Turf and you're
going to sell the [__] out of it sell
[__] [__] out of it why don't you sell
those old classic drugs from the '90s
Like Cocaine from the '90s okay so yangs
you'll take my dead roommate spot oh the
twins are you kidding me Yang are you
high of course
yeah put's your guns down guns down Doug
my name's not Doug it's Schmid and guess
what cops oh my God yeah everybody knows
you guys look like the stars of a cop
show called Hawaiian dads
these actors are so good with their
reactions I love it we have way more
guns than you drop
your that's a good
point this really your entire plan or
maybe we had a far more elaborate plan
maybe my partner has a tracking device
in his pocket right now may what you
have track device I don't have it's the
one thing you were supposed to remember
the [__] dumbest possible thing is
letting two cops blah blah blah while
other cops are getting in position to
bust their [__] in oh so you mean I
brought the tracking yeah what's up now
huh such a real argument that's in [__]
yeah spring break
yourself we shoot in Jump Street oh ah
his BR the nerd alerts we love him don't
do it leather face
oh protect that backpack at all cost
save it for
Terra please I need it you know what
happens in a shootout they always kidnap
the girl not always Mercedes you're
coming with me [__] please I ain't
going nowhere with you oh oh that hurts
shot me in my foot move move faster now
my time you shot me in myam
foot Mercedes just took my dad that way
okay we're on it going go by the way you
look really
attractive that would have been
great
Lamborghini yeah baby dream car
police police
here huh ow what do we do uh we just
spit up you okay with that yes he's
strong enough now and I need to drive
your faster on foot what I don't get to
drive the lambo no go come on let's go
[__] about the lambo just go I can't let
him go you're going to have to take him
take care of her okay how do you drive
this thing you got to let her drive you
bro it's true I'm sure chaning Tatum was
actually really sad about that in real
life like dude can we just switch this
please
[Music]
bit it does make sense to have Jonah
Hill save Ice Cube yeah just got to
accept him that's one of
[Laughter]
best let me you get
[Applause]
crazy
bmobile that is a good analogy see
people I'm not the only one who makes
comic book references he's the only one
on this channel just kidding this is
enough you
[Music]
need
cool awesome well done smooth get over
here I'm
handcuffed hole a nice parking job I'll
be right back I got to go he should
probably be taken to the hospital he got
shot in the foot
[Music]
whoa nice
tackle get your fre hands
off how the hell well I guess you would
find him cuz he's got the pink backpack
yeah then you better fight like two men
hey hey oh damn uhoh yeah but is zuk
going to come in and help him he's his
brother yeah I'm not going to fight a
girl so just stop shouldn't matter have
you thought of me as a person instead of
a woman you would hit me and not feel
bad about it oh wa girl was this guy
just randomly sitting there watching he
looks drugged out too he's so high oh
waa is there blood in my eye blood in my
eye
oh that's a little better that's a
little
better is this their meat
cute no what no what were you doing what
am I doing why did you try to kiss me I
try to kiss you yes you did oh you're so
weird yeah OHA you haven't went to kiss
me the whole time I never once wanted to
kiss you never no oh my God you gave me
kiss me eyes no I didn't the eyes were
eyes I just got punched in the face eyes
they weren't kiss me eyes this guy is
just sitting here like what's I love it
I'm going to give you an out by punching
you in the face okay and then we're
going to go back to fighting and we'll
Pretend This Never Happened cuz I feel
so awkward oh it's so
great zuk help
him yeah blow up doll help him out help
him out oh maybe he doesn't need zuk's
help whoa cool
nice oh
wow it's like I'm onchan Tatum oh oh
nice cool that girl's probably so drunk
she's not even feeling anything oh W
she's a dancer that
School whoa
awesome oh my God oh my God and then
they make
out is that a
plastic imagine how about this you want
a little
fun is that yes
[Music]
oh vient
I'm I'm impressed you caught up to me
you probably haven't run that fast you
played stickball in the field behind old
pop wiggle be's sweet
shop I have a clean shot Schmid and
don't take the shot maybe I want to take
a dirty shot kind of like the dirty shot
you took on my daughter he didn't know
and didn't take a dirty shot at your
daughter we talked a lot and we care
about each other all the good qualities
you have I could feel inside of my
don't take the shot taking the shot I'll
take the nobody take the shot is that
Maya behind him I thought I saw Maya
behind him yeah now Maya what oh you go
handle the ghost he's on the roof I'm on
it I got it oh good job on the cups baby
[Music]
girl oh he's running out of
steam it's me it's me I love when they
do these transitions from the sidebars
yeah dude you were right that Lambo was
just can't hear that right now it's a
shitty made car it's not
good it does ride too low to the asphalt
for my tastes got go we have to wait for
P I missed it did they say oh oh he's
going to take a bullet for
him maybe y oh well that's what that's
that's what happened last remember
completely miss the other shoulder yeah
in the exact spot in the other shoulder
he completely mistimed it nice call back
I tried to take a bullet for you man but
you didn't not the thought counts it's
taking the
bullet cover me I'm going to go long
okay oh this is where he they get to I
wish you could ride fly with me and I
feel like they're doing that
[Music]
now whoa later Wolverine nice Bye by
terminate
[Music]
ha whoa nice how's he able to hold on
he's got a gunshot
[Music]
amazing is he going to make it I think
he will after all those fails he's got
to have a
success they're going to fly
[Music]
together
yeah well earned nice I did
[Applause]
it you do I couldn't leave you hanging
man what are you talking about I was
fine I had it oh oh
no oh my God I got
you oh damn and they said they don't
have the
budget clearly not for stunts that for
stunts they do they do I guess you could
drop them in the water you don't hold me
down man you lift me up literally and
figura Hey listen there's a grenade in
my shorts can you reach it oh yeah
that's right I forgot about
[Music]
that is
it oh that's great Oh no I got it in my
mouth say something cool when you throw
it something cool
hey nice no not the money not the money
we need the
money oh feel so
alive feel so alive for the very first
time let's party Like It's
1999 dude I miss you so much man I miss
you too you're like a tiny little flower
seed I was I was clenching you in my
fist but a flower and K growing in a
fist fire I'm in thank God this is what
I've always wanted just me and you buddy
yay dude we're even about to arm thing
okay right what what do you want to do
all right just just get it over with oh
my god really raise my arm I don't want
you to hit the bone
two
three oh no oh my goodness no for your
next mission you two sons of [__] are
going to medical school what
what yeah nice I can't wait time foreign
exchange students awesome in Russia in
[Music]
Russia hey 24 jumpster I love it next
assignment a semester at
C This is So Meta I love
[Music]
it ready art school I actually want to
see all these movies me
too veterinary
school she may look any different to you
no set oh hey I got new glasses yeah may
just got some new glasses man God damn
definitely looks the
same do this oh my
goodness I mean sometimes there are
different castings for the same
character really glad you're back what
are you talking about what contract
dispute I've been here the whole time
how about a Flight Academy don't be
afraid to
yeah give me some Top Gun
[__] you're Jump Street right Richard
greo he was in the original 21 Jump
Street oh [__] video game video G I
want to play this game we should react
to the game yeah at least the cool car
works in the
game I would buy that lunchbox no you
would buy the the pink backpack as long
as it comes with the money in
it don't sh my dick sign 6 hours of
makeup we're getting too old for this
[__]
nice oh God
whoa they're pulling out all the stops
love
it Three Amigos or the Two Amigos I
guess do
Amigos 21 going into space those credits
are fire yeah it was all worth it just
for the credits oh my gosh that was so
good all righty time to get a little bit
serious so around the holiday season we
often focus on getting gifts for others
but it's also important to consider the
gifts that we give to ourselves
personally I found that maintaining
mental health balance is a continuous
Journey cuz like I mentioned before I've
been diagnosed with type 2 bipolar ADHD
and PTSD and in a lot of ways I've also
grown up in the last few years on camera
with you guys and therapy has been a
crucial part of my life before the
channel even and like many any of you my
anxiety and depression seems to magnify
this time of year still don't quite
understand the winter Blues but it does
however therapy does help me navigate
the ups and downs and stay grounded for
the most part and while I have my own
approach to therapy I understand
everyone's path is unique and that's why
we are proud to be sponsored by better
help this week it's an online platform
that makes therapy accessible and tailor
to your needs and I know a few people
who have discovered therapy via better
help and it has been transformative you
start with a questionnaire that helps
match you with the licensed therapist
and the best part and an important part
you can switch therapist anytime uring
the right fit for you better help is all
about convenience and flexibility it
fits into your schedule and it's all
online so whether you're looking to
start therapy for the first time or
continue your journey better help can be
a great option so in the season of
giving remember to give yourself what
you need to with better help take that
step towards your better self so you can
visit betterhelp.com rejects for 10% off
your first month that's better
hp.com rejects take care and stay
healthy reject Nation happy holidays and
so much fun Andrew you say your thoughts
first first before I say my thoughts if
you could only get one of those credited
films which one for me for me it's the
Top Gun one but I mean I'm obsessed yeah
but there's so many different I mean
also too I'm rooster so I got to go with
Top Gun but I don't know they all look
so much fun is there a specific one I
was going to say the Top Gun one Andrew
get out of
town um the other one I think it' be fun
if they went to Beauty School Beauty
School Dropout veterinarian one I mean
I'm an animal lover so I could that one
would be fun uh I I I love this movie um
I know probably everyone's like well did
you like it more in the FR I I mean I
love them both um but you know I also
love too um I know I said the word
probably like 50,000 times during the
reaction but I really I know the first
one was kind of meta too but I really
appreciated just so much how meta was it
just like literally grabbed it by the
balls how meta was but I just appreciate
like oh but also too I love how they
called out a lot of the forh especially
with Nick at the very beginning
literally said what the whole movie was
going to be about and what was going to
happen um except we didn't call out the
girl the drug dealer when we were I
wonder if we would have gone back and
listened to it if there was any mention
of like probably a new person coming
through if we would have gotten that I
don't know I really I like that twist I
I did too and I really like that
character that that might be one of my
favorite one-on-one like with uh you
know the main uh the protagonist and
antagonist fighting
their dialogue alone like obviously like
fight scene not the greatest fight scene
but the dialogue going on like you kiss
you give me the kiss me eyes and like
the dial I got I don't even like you
yeah I got to say that the Imp I mean
the Improv again in the first film
phenomenal but the Improv here in this
one again um the thing I loved again the
the strength of the film though for me
though besides the comedy and and the
action of course was the chemistry once
again between Channing Tatum and Jonah
they are just so good together what did
you think of the film keep I loved it I
just think it's so fun to see them like
we already knew that they were going to
go to college and it was nice to see
that Channing Tatum's character finally
got to be at college and have a lot of
fun but it's actually I mean it's it's I
feel like that's true in real life when
you go to college with a good friend or
like a girlfriend or a boyfriend or
something that college like breaks you
up and you need to go and live your life
for a little while and then come back
together with what you know if you yeah
and they really obviously love each
other and belong together but I really
liked the side plot with Kurt Russell's
son how he found um a new BFF and it's
so like all or nothing in the beginning
you like find this person you're like
man because you're so used to he was so
used to Jonah Hill's character and then
he with Kurt Russell son I obviously
don't know any of the characters names
leave me out of it um that it's so fast
and so Furious and then he realizes like
oh is this wait is this it u meaning the
twps and a PO can get a bit of Snooze
festy and I like that plot a lot and
especially with Kurt Russell's son at
the end going he belongs with him like
he was so supportive which I thought was
great well I mentioned their chemistry
is so good I mean you got Jonah Hill
with the Improv and then obviously chain
Tatum with the reactions they just work
so in tandem but in terms of
characterizations I I also like you just
mentioned I love that in the first film
like in high school obviously Jonah Hill
was not very popular he didn't he asked
the girl to or wanted to ask the girl to
prom but was uh she kind of gave him a
sign like uh do not ask me I'm not going
to say yes kind of thing and so it was
more tailored towards hey this is kind
of you know it's it's more for him like
he he's like living his dream here and
then this film is now more for chain
tamam I do like the whole plot line
though in terms of characterization for
you know they kind of got a break a
little bit apart so they can also have
an understanding of like okay it's good
to get a little time apart so they can
see that they do need each other as well
but I mean you did make a good point
though that college can like I mean it's
that is a time where like you know you
can you know you lose friendships or you
just go your own separate ways you need
the time apart because there's so many
new people and new things to do and
you'll find new people that you can make
connections with which is why they end
up in an open relationship for a while
open investigation yeah I'm like I feel
like it's everyone's story if you go
from high school to college they're like
let's have it be open for a minute um
which is uh a great uh metaphor which I
think is very funny but I also liked
that even in the emotional moments like
when they're breaking up when they're
like do you should it be open and he
goes in to hug them he's like don't hug
me right now it was as we both said we
like we were kind of sad we I really
believed that I thought they did a great
job of making it believable and not
laying it on to thi with it being like
uh extra corny it was more realistic cuz
both of them were really grounded and
great actors um so the moments when they
did get emotional even though it's
supposed to play into the comedy
slightly it was still very grounded and
realistic which I really really liked
yeah um they did a great job with that
for sure and then also to just uh going
to your point about playing into to
twist too with that the the roommate
being you know the did they by the oh oh
Eric are you awake no I'm
late he's
pregnant oh no sorry Eric that's a nice
call back uh what I was going to say is
uh you know playing into twist as well I
didn't p i mean obviously I didn't see
that twist coming but also I didn't see
uh Ice Cube's daughter and the whole uh
him hooking up with Ice Cube's daughter
uh I thought that was hysterical and
also too like you know we talked about
like I love when Ice Cube just rips into
Jonah Hill's
so I thought that was sooi and then also
to you talk about the ending when you
know Jonah Hill has to get into the
Lamborghini has to save you know Ice
Cube's character obviously has to get a
little Redemption from him because he's
having a little bit of an affair with
his daughter but also too he's got to
stop uh not only the bad guy but the one
who's been insulting him you know the
the uh I guess his girlfriend's roommate
who's been insulting him so it was
actually a perfect uh mix there but then
um it also sense too from that
perspective but I just I I loved I love
that twist into uh in there but I
thought you know the film did a good job
being pretty unpredictable in certain
aspects yeah and I thought that it was a
perfect ending for me because what he
said to him is I just that wish that we
could fly together and that's
legitimately what they do at the end
when he jumps on the helicopter finally
does it they are actually flying
together and I liked that they didn't
actually do an exposition and say it out
loud like hey man look we're flying
together cuz like you could just I mean
maybe not everybody caught that but they
were flying together and I thought that
was great um so I would give this my
rating for this would be like seven and
a half I I was going to go I was going
to say 8.5 or eight eight or 8.5 I mean
Super Fun movie seven and a half eight
around there and again it it it's funny
uh there's some unexpected twists and uh
again there's an emotional pull and the
chemistry between the two main stars is
just they it's they're so good together
and a lot you could tell there's so much
improv which is again it's not an easy
thing to do I've tried so much improv in
my life it's it's a very difficult thing
to do so I can only imagine how many
takes for certain different scenes that
they had to do or I know I know watching
certain things I'm like I can only
imagine how many times they had to do
that or like is that the first thing
that came to either Jonah Hill's mind or
or even the again the the character who
ended up being uh the main uh bad guy or
bad character antagonist like she had
some really good improv skills as well
yeah she's great she's from uh the show
where it's mostly all the three guys
they all do improv um she looks so what
what have I seen her in you know you
guys you know I'm terrible at all things
names movies have I seen it I don't know
my brain doesn't remember but it's
they're the three of them they're in the
house it's like uh whatever they're all
Two and a Half Men no no no it's a TV
show um it'll come to me she's in it
she's a star with along with the three
um guys who all do a bunch of improv
there's obviously a lot of people from
UCB in this uh there was a UCB poster in
the background the Obey poster um and
all of these most of these actors at
least the side ones uh are UCB people
that you could actually catch at the UCB
stage because they still do improv um
and uh it will come to me work a
I think is the name of the show in my
brain I saw you guys know what I'm
talking about Adam Lavine and then the
other Adam Lavine is that his name guys
help me out just leave it in the
comments I know it's Workaholics but I'm
not I'm not good with all the names
obviously you guys know me by now um so
okay he's at eight I'm at like seven and
a half eight we loved it you got any
last words to say no just I really uh
enjoyed it I would love if they made
another one I don't know if they're I
mean this is 2014 so I don't know if
they're going to make another one I know
they had an idea a while back of doing
uh the 21 Jump Street franchise and I
think we talked about this in the last
video 21 Jump Street meets Men In Black
I don't know oh I would die if they did
that I mean yeah I mean with how meta it
got in in especially in this film I I
mean I'd be open to the idea especially
with these two coming back but I would
love if they just did another one but uh
well I mean I don't I don't know at this
point I but again you can never say
never because with how many sequels
we've seen come out uh especially
nowadays like it doesn't matter how long
you know and I mean this is 2014 it came
out so we do have it has been a while
but you never know they could be like
let's do it we miss it I would I would
love to see another one but if this if
this is how it ends with just these two
I I I love both these films they're so
good their chemistry is unbelievable we
support it and we love it don't forget
to guys to leave a like leave a comment
ring the bell tell us how cool we are uh
buy t-shirt you guys know all the best
juice join patreon we call you super
sexy we love you and we will see you on
the next one
[Music]
goodbye